general
shortly his senior advisor to the
director general the leader the act
accelerator
we have dr kate o'brien director of
immunization vaccines and biologicals
on the health emergency center for
ukraine we have
dr sousa fall assistant director general
for the emergencies
uh response
dr adelheit martian senior emergency
officer at the emergencies program
and dr flavio salio
he's the network lead for the emergency
medical teams dmt network lead at who
and last but not least joining us
remotely is dr maria angela simao
assistant director general for access to
medicines and
health products
with this again welcome and let me hand
to the director general for the opening
remarks
thank you thank you christian
good morning good afternoon and good
evening
after several weeks of declines reported
cases of covet 19 are once again
increasing globally
especially in parts of asia
these increases are occurring despite
reductions in testing in some countries
which means the cases we're seeing are
just the tip of the iceberg
and we know that when cases increase
so do there's
continued local outbreaks and surges are
to be expected particularly in areas
where measures to prevent transmission
have been lifted
however
there are unacceptably high levels of
mortality in many countries
especially where vaccination levels are
low among susceptible populations
each country is facing a different
situation with different challenges
but the pandemic is not
over
i repeat the pandemic is not over
we call on all countries to remain
vigilant
continue to vaccinate test
sequence provide early care for patients
and apply common sense public health
measures
to protect
health workers and the public
we continue to call on everyone to be
vaccinated where vaccines are available
and we continue to work night and day to
expand access to vaccines everywhere
now to ukraine
who's priority remains to support health
workers and the health system to
continue to provide care
to meet immediate health needs
we have now established supply lines to
many cities of ukraine
but challenges with access remain
so far we have sent about 100 metric
tons of supplies including oxygen
insulin surgical supplies anesthetics
and blood transfusion kits
other equipment including oxygen
generators electrical generators
the free platters
and more have also been delivered
and we're preparing to send a further
108 metric tons
we are coordinating the deployment of 20
emergency medical teams of experts from
many countries
pending a formal request for assistance
from ukraine's ministry of health
and we have opened a field office in
poland to support our operations in
ukraine
and to coordinate the response to the
health needs of refugees
but
we're facing financial constraints in
our ability to deliver the support
needed
so far
who has received just 8 million u.s
dollars of our appeal for 57.5
millionaires dollars
huge amounts of money are being spent on
weapons
we ask donors to invest in ensuring that
civilians in ukraine and refugees
receive the care they need
and we continue to call for attacks on
health care to stop
more than 300 health facilities are
along conflict lines
or in areas that russia no controls
and a further 600 facilities are within
10 kilometers of the conflict line
since the beginning of the war in
ukraine who has verified 43 attacks on
healthcare
who condemns all attacks on health care
wherever they occur
tragically
ukraine is not the only place where
patients health workers facilities
infrastructure and supply are under
attack
2022 is only 75 days old but already who
has verified 89 attacks on health care
around the world
in afghanistan burkina faso the
democratic republic of the congo
libya nigeria the occupied palestinian
territory sudan the syrian arab republic
and of course ukraine
all together
these attacks have injured 53 people and
killed 35 including health workers
that includes eight polio health workers
who were killed in afghanistan last
month
attacks on health care not only endanger
lives
they deprive people of urgently needed
care and break already strained health
systems
although ukraine is the focus of the
world's attention
it's far from the only crisis to which
who is responding
in yemen roughly two-thirds of the
population
more than 20 million people are
estimated to be in need of health
assistance
in afghanistan more than half the
population is in need
with widespread malnutrition and a surge
in measles among many other challenges
and in ethiopia six million people in
chicago have been under blockade by
ethiopian and eritrean forces for almost
500 days
sealed off from the outside world
there is almost no fuel
no cash and no communications
no food aid has been delivered since the
middle of december
83
of the population is fully insecure
our partners are running out of what
little food they have
and the fuel to transport it
about three quarters of health
facilities assessed by doublitch have
been damaged or
destroyed in february
who airlifted more than 33 metric tons
of medicines and other supplies to
tigray
enough for 300 000 people
the first time we have been able to
deliver supplies since july last year
in the past two weeks who and our
partners have distributed supplies to 65
health facilities integral
but much more is needed and we are now
preparing to send an additional 95
metric tons of supplies but no
permission has been given yet
we estimate that 2 200 metric tons of
emergency health supplies are needed
to respond to urgent health needs
integrai
only 117 metric tons have been delivered
less than one percent of what is needed
but with no fuel
even if we can get supplies in getting
them to where they need to go is very
difficult or impossible
the humanitarian situation in the
neighboring alpha region also continues
to deteriorate
with tens of thousands of people
displaced in need of food shelter and
health services
but while the neighboring regions of
afar and amhara are also affected we
have had far better access to those two
regions than we have integra
what is the impact of all this
people are dying
there is no treatment for 46 000 people
who need treatment for hiv
and the program has been abundant
people with tuberculosis hypertension
the habits and cancer are also not being
treated
and may have died
as a result of the lack of fuel
some of our partners are having to scale
back their operations
the situation integra is catastrophic
the blockade on communications
including on journalists being able to
report from tigray means it remains a
forgotten crisis
out of sight
and out of mind
yes i'm from tigre
and this crisis affects me
my family and my friends
very personally
but at the director general of wha i
have a duty to protect and promote
health wherever it's under threat
and
there is nowhere on earth where the
health of millions of people is more
under threat than integrity
just as we continue to call on russia to
make peace in ukraine
so we continue to call on
ethiopia and eritrea to end the blockade
the siege
and allow safe access for humanitarian
supplies
and workers
to save
lives
peace is the only solution
in ukraine yemen afghanistan and
ethiopia
christian back to you
thank you very much
dr teddrus let me now open the floor to
questions from the media
to get into the queue to ask questions
you need to raise your hand using the
raise your hand
icon on your screen and do not forget to
unmute yourself when
called upon and we'll start with corinne
gretler from bloomberg corinne please
unmute yourself
hi thank you um i have a question for um
kate
um i wanted to ask about medicago's
covet vaccine co-defense
i see that its eoi has not been accepted
would you be able to help me understand
what that means exactly does that mean
that co-defense
will not be considered for eol
evaluation at all
and then
also um you know why is that perhaps
because of the tobacco link with philip
morris just because i know that there
are some strict rules around tobacco
cooperation with the fctc
um
or if there is another reason and i just
want to understand what that means
basically and whether medicago can
appeal that decision at all
um and sorry just a super quick add-on
has the war in ukraine affected the
who's approval process of the sputnik
vaccine in any way
thank you so much
thank you very much corinne um
i think we'll first go to dr marian
hiller simone assistant director general
for access to medicines and health
products
my angela please go ahead
thank you thank you corinne for the two
questions actually first on the medic
cargo you know that
the medication has applied for an
emergency listing by the region but
due to its connections it's owned by
tobacco
by a philip morris international
partially owned by philip ward's
international so the process is put on
hold because it's well known that double
joe and u.n has a very strict
policy regarding the
engagement with tobacco and arms
industry so the process is put on board
it's very likely that it won't be
accepted for the emergency use listing
by the blajo on the sputnik yes we were
supposed to go to to do inspections in
in the in russia on the starting on the
7th of march and we we these inspections
were
postponed for a later date so
the assessment has been uh
the assessment and local inspections
have been affected because of the
situation and
an even situation regarding flight
options and also the the financial
issues related to
to support with credit cards and some
more operational
issues and this is being discussed with
the russian applicants and new dates
will be set as soon as possible thank
you
thank you very much my angela
the next question goes to isabel sacco
from fa isabel please unmute yourself
isabel to hear us please unmute yourself
hello yes now you do it
yes you're good please go ahead
hello do you hear me
yes we do
hello
sorry okay it seems like isabelle
doesn't hear us
i'll give it a second to see if we can
fix the connection
if not then we'll first go to ashwin
from the observer times that indian will
come to isabel in a moment when you have
fixed that so ashwin observer times
india please unmute yourself
uh thank you for considering my question
my question is is c
dna microarray technology
useful to get ideal vaccine
characteristic for cova 19 disease
thank you
ashwin can you please repeat we're not
sure we got the full question
uh it's c dna microarray technology
useful to get ideal vaccine
characteristic
for coved 19 disease
thank you
thank you very much
go to dr k o'brien for a start please
so the question of um the composition of
vaccines and the technology to be able
to determine that composition is still
you know really an open matter for
research and evaluation of vaccines as
you know we have a number of different
platforms of vaccines some of them are
based on the the virus itself some of
them are based on either rna or dna
sequences of
components of the virus so there's no
one technology um that is sort of the
ideal technology or the or the the
critical way forward i think the
important part of this is um this is uh
an area of science that has been
evolving very very quickly over the past
year and importantly contributing not
only to the development of very
effective covid vaccines but also
deploying that technology towards other
vaccines
so cdna microarray technology is not
something specific that we're focused on
as as that particular technology i
really want to emphasize the the range
of options on vaccines which have all
been those ones that have achieved uh
wha eul have all delivered on the
protection against especially the severe
end of the disease spectrum thank you
thank you very much dr o'brien
i will try for a moment to come back to
isabel sacco from fa isabel let's try
again
isabelle if you hear us please unmute
yourself
yes please go ahead
please unmute yourself
thank you for my uh for taking my
question um i'm just wondering what is
causing
the rise in infections again are we
about to face a new wave
what is causing the rise in
we got it okay thank you very much and
dr maria van kerkov please
so thanks for the question it's a
combination of factors um for which
we're seeing an increase in case
detections again around the world
in the last week we saw an eight percent
increase in cases detected with more
than 11 million cases reported to who
and this is display despite a
significant reduction in testing that's
occurring worldwide
so it's a combination of factors
that is resulting in this increase first
is we still have omicron
which is transmitting at a very intense
level around the world we have
sublimages of omicron ba.1 and ba.2
bi.2 is more transmissible than ba.1
even
and this is the most transmissible
variant we have seen of the sars kobe 2
virus to date
in the context of lifting of public
health and social measures lifting of
the use of masks lifting of
physical distancing
lifting of restrictions of limiting
people's movement this will provide the
virus an opportunity to spread
we have also
incomplete vaccination coverage in many
parts of the world and in particular
among people who are at risk of
developing severe disease
and we have huge amounts of
misinformation that's out there the
misinformation that omicron is mild
misinformation that the pandemic is over
misinformation that this is the last
variant that we will have to deal with
this is really causing a lot of
confusion that's out there so we are
seeing increases in case detection
around the world for a number of reasons
these are the same factors that have
been driving transmission of this virus
since the beginning of the pandemic
we completely understand um that the
world needs to von from kovid19 wants to
move on from covid19
um but
um this virus
spreads very efficiently between people
and if we don't have the right
interventions in place the virus will
take opportunities
to continue to spread and the more the
virus spreads the more opportunities it
has to change
so it's a number of factors the good
news is that we have the tools that can
reduce the spread
we know that masking works we know that
physical distancing works we know that
vaccination saves lives
and so um we need to continue as the dg
said in his speech just now and as the
director general has been saying since
the beginning of this pandemic it's
about a layered approach and using these
tools most effectively
and making sure that we not only save
lives with vaccination earlier clinical
care good testing but we also take
measures to reduce the risk
so we are concerned that we're starting
to see an increase in case detection
again
and again it's within our control
we do have some power over being able to
limit the spread and we really need to
remain vigilant and do what we can where
we can to reduce the spread
just maybe add to that point because i
think when we look at these data and
deep into them when we look at the
hospitalizations and deaths again
the overwhelming majority of people who
are getting very sick and dying
are vulnerable individuals older
individuals people with underlying
conditions
who have not been vaccinated or not have
not received a full course of effective
vaccines and we again need to restate
the importance in every country this is
not just a north-south issue in every
single country needs to look again at
vaccination levels and it's most
vulnerable whether it's using booster
policies or not and ensure at the very
minimum that every individual who is
vulnerable has two doses of effective
vaccine and in situations where boosters
are available the
policy is in place
as well because
i i think we'll see this virus
is still as maria said ray fit
it's still moving around quite easily
and in the context of waning immunity
and still
and the fact that vaccines don't work
perfectly against infection the
likelihood is that this virus will echo
around the world it'll be high in some
parts and sometimes it'll move and be
higher again it'll move to another area
where
immunity is waning and the virus will
pick up pockets of susceptibility
and will survive in those pockets
for months and months until another
pocket of susceptibility opens up this
is how viruses work they establish
themselves within a community and
they'll move quickly to the next
community if it's unprotected but what
can happen is in if communities around a
virus are well protected the virus can
sustain itself even in small communities
it can stay there
it can rest there and then wait
until uh susceptibility grows
in in other communities we've seen this
looking at bruce and polio and other
places
so i do think it's very important that
we recognize that the transmission of
this disease will occur it will wax and
it will wane it has not settled down
into a purely seasonal or predictable
pattern yet so the idea that we're
through it in the northern hemisphere
now and we've got to wait till next
winter i think when we look at
increasing rates for example of cases
and debts and the likes of the uk i
think we need to be very very very
vigilant we need to be very cautious we
need to watch this very carefully and we
need to focus on getting the most
vulnerable
appropriately
vaccinated and we need to do that as
quickly as possible in every country
thank you very much dr ryan
next question goes to lizzie davis from
the guardian lizzie please unmute
yourself
hi uh thanks for taking my question um
i'd like to know if you could give any
more detail about the 43 attacks on
health care
in ukraine um specifically what kind of
establishments you're talking about when
you talk about health care um
where have most of the attacks taken
place are you able to give any
geographic information and
do you also have any information on how
many healthcare workers in ukraine have
been injured or even killed in the same
time period thank you
[Music]
thank you very much and we'll start with
dr sosie follower assistant director
general for the emergency program
in
[Music]
[Music]
yes
um thank you so sorry and
i think it's important to reflect here
that this is the problem the dg referred
to this we're only very short part into
this year and we have never seen
globally
never seen this rate with tax on health
care
health is becoming a target in these
situations it's becoming part of the
strategy and tactics of war it is
entirely entirely unacceptable it is
against international humanitarian law
and in fact under international
humanitarian law
conflicting parties are actually
instructed to specifically take measures
to avoid
attacking
or inadvertently destroying or hurting
health workers or health facilities they
don't bear responsibility not just to
not attack they actually bear
responsibility to ensure that they don't
attack to identify those facilities to
deconflict those facilities and to
ensure that they do not as part of their
prosecution of war attack those
facilities so it is not only against
human and international humanitarian law
to carry out attacks like this it is
actually in the responsibility of all
parties i might say all parties in
conflict uh to do so we are as the dg
again has said working very hard with
many partners to get emergency medical
teams on the ground but how how can we
put emergency medical teams on the
ground if the very facilities that they
may want to go and support are going to
be attacked and going to be bombed and
going to going to suffer uh catastrophic
damage we're in it
this crisis is reaching a point where
the
the health system in ukraine is is
teetering on the brink it is doing
exceptionally well it needs to be
supported it needs to be shored up it
needs to be given the basic tools
to save lives part of that is deploying
teams in to support that
but how can you do that in all
conscience
if the very infrastructure that those
people will go into support is being
under direct attack and i don't know
flavio salio is back from leading our
emt initiatives in in ukraine and maybe
flavio would like to comment on this but
this is a really this issue is more
important than bricks and mortar this
isn't just about the destruction
of
of buildings this is about the
destruction of hope this is about taking
away the very thing
that gives people the reason to live the
the fact that their families can be
taken care of that they can be cured if
they're sick that they can be treated if
they're injured this is this is a the
most basic of human rights and it has
been directly denied
to people and
we are then in a position where we can't
send assistance to those people because
the very act of attacking those
facilities are not taking care to avoid
those facilities means we can't send the
appropriate help when it's needed
thanks authority yes it's becoming uh
for sure a challenge to ensure that the
right level of support reached
facilities we we have been in touch with
the hospital requesting support in
particular specialized care where
basically
external medical team can bring the the
added value
and support the local health system the
challenges remain obviously safety of of
the staff
safety as well of the patients
themselves they become become today the
the most the challenging uh point at
this stage
there is as well a significant component
that include evacuation of of patients
from the areas in which are targeted
patients that obviously suffer from
chronic condition and does require as
well
support so there is a
ongoing evaluation of the system that
can facilitate
medical evaluation towards the borders
then obviously across facilities uh in
in europe that will uh accommodate them
the self
as a last point i think the the augment
in the capacity through temporary
facility could be other options but
challenged by the element that dr ryan
described in terms of the conflictions
as well and ensuring that if we bring
such kind of capacity is recognized by
obviously the parties to uh to the
conflict thanks
thank you very much all for these
explanations
um next question goes to sara nui from
the telegraph sarah please unmute
yourself
hi there uh two quick questions that's
okay um firstly you've talked a lot
about the risk of covert spreading in
ukraine and other infectious diseases um
obviously as mike just said the health
system is struggling but do you have any
evidence of increasing cover cases or
measles or tb um
as people flee and secondly probably for
maria could you just tell us a bit more
about the global spread of ba 0.2 and is
there any evidence that it's more severe
or more likely to evade vaccines thank
you
let's start with the emergencies
question on ukraine on the diseases and
the situation there
dr martian please
yes thank you um we we have stated
previously that the kovit 19
surveillance system in in ukraine is is
holding is strong is detecting cases we
see at the same time
that the testing
that the the testing has has decreased
still
we have captured now i think something
like more than 30 000 um
new cases and we're trying to to place
that if anything it indicates an
increase this is something that that we
have suspected but we also need to say
that there is a decreasing in access and
and capacity to to deal with these cases
we do understand that between the 23rd
february to the 8th of march there was a
22 percent
decrease in the number of beds
available with oxygen for example
um and the 20
decrease in the number of intensive beds
when they are most needed for some of
those health risks that we have pointed
out previously and that is trauma and
injuries um and an increase in in
in acute
conditions due to to non-communicable
diseases that that we have already
pointed out
thank you very much
and doctor
christopher
questions
[Music]
certain promiscuity
thank you much doctor fall and we try to
covet part of the question for dr van
kerkov
um thanks sir for the question about
ba.2 so
in the last 30 days of the more than 400
000 sequences that have been with sample
dates in the last 30 days 99.9 of those
have been omicron and among those about
75 percent of those are ba.2 compared to
ba.1 about 25 rba.2 b8.1 let me say that
again
of the sequences that are available
about 75
are ba.2 and 25 of those are ba.1 all of
these are omicron and all of these are
variants of concern so we are seeing an
increase in the proportion of ba.2 that
is detected however the amount of
testing that is happening worldwide as
we have mentioned previously is dropping
substantially so our ability to track
this virus our ability to track ba.2 is
compromised because testing is reduced
and you can't sequence those who you
don't test
so we need a very strong surveillance
system around the world for covet 19.
despite all of the challenges that we
are facing we still need to maintain
testing we still need to maintain robust
sequencing and making sure that we have
good geographic representation of the
sequences that are shared so that we can
really track this virus in real time
we as who are working with literally
thousands of public health professionals
and scientists around the world to be
able to track virus evolution and look
at what these changes mean in terms of
our ability to control the spread or
reduce the spread our ability to use
tools effectively and of course to look
at the use of vaccines
we should say that vaccines covet 19
vaccines remain incredibly effective at
preventing severe disease and death
including against omicron
you asked a question specifically about
severity
we do know that omicron is less severe
compared to delta
we do not see changes in severity of
ba.2 compared to ba.1 at population
levels
however with huge numbers of cases you
will see an increase in hospitalizations
and we've seen this in country after
country the sheer volume of cases that
we have seen
has really uh translated into increased
hospitalizations and that in turn has in
it has translated into increased deaths
what we can say when we look at deaths
in countries around the world as mike
pointed out earlier as the dg has
pointed out the deaths are primarily
occurring in people who are not
vaccinated or people who've only had one
dose of vaccine so it is absolutely
critical that those that people receive
vaccines around the world
in all countries and in particular
people who are at risk of developing
severe disease
if you look at some countries right now
that are experiencing high amounts of
mortality
compared to previous waves look at the
proportion of those populations that
have actually received the vaccines and
look in particular how many above the
age of 60
those who have underlying conditions who
have received vaccines and in fact in a
lot of those countries that proportion
is quite low so it is really critical
not just to vaccinate but to ensure that
those who are at most risk receive the
vaccines first because the vaccines are
saving lives
we cannot stress this enough
so it is really important that we
keep up the systems that have been put
in place for covid for strong
surveillance strong testing getting
patients into the clinical care pathway
early increased vaccination it's this
layered approach that is really going to
help us get a handle on kova 19 and we
have the power right now to take the
death and devastation out of covid but
we have to make sure that vaccines are
received by all people and particularly
those who are most at risk in all
countries
thank you very much dr van kerkov and we
managed to reach isabel sucker from fa
in writing so answer is already talking
about ba dot one and b and o two we read
out the question she has in that
um what do you know about the new
supposed variant combining ba.1 and b802
where has it been identified and is it a
source of
so i i'll i'll take a stab at that
question i'm not aware of a combination
of ba.1 and ba.2
you may be referring to the recombinant
that we mentioned
last week which was a combination of a
y.4 which is delta and ba.1 which is
omicron and that has been detected in in
three countries and it's very low level
of circulation as we are aware um but
not aware of a combination of ba.1 and
ba.2 these are sublineages of omicron
again ba.1 and ba.2 are omicron and they
are already classified as variants of
concern
misunderstood as well
those subliminals can co-circulate so
you can it's not that there's a combined
virus what you have is multiple versions
of the virus circulating at the same
time and depending on the situation
one can gain the upper hand over the
other and it depends sometimes on just
when it arrived
so for example the predominance of ba2
in many asian countries may be that ba2
emerged slightly later and has driven
the
the ongoing surge in asia but there's
still be a one there's still other
variants and lineages causing disease so
it's not a combination of both as in one
virus but a combined effect of both when
they're both transmitting
thank you very much both very important
explanations um
next question goes to bianca rottier
from global brazil and bianca please
unmute yourself
hi christian tate thanks a lot for
taking my question and in fact it's uh
follow-up with isabel sacco question
because
brazil
said that the
the country
has now two cases of this
um
delta chrome they are calling it delta
chrome so i'm not sure if i understood
the
the answer because there they they are
saying that uh
it's a
epsilon dot 4
so
yeah if you can explain better and uh
yeah if you have information about this
thanks a lot
all right let's go and do the
explanation dr van kerkov
yes thank you so this uh recombinant is
a combination of a y dot four which is
delta to sub lineage of delta and ba.1
which is sublineage of omicron and this
recombinant has been detected in a
number of countries i mentioned three
countries you've just mentioned brazil
now as we look more as we do more
sequencing it is possible that this
recombinant virus will be detected in
other countries
but it is circulating as we understand
at very low levels
you